may I ask if it isn't too presumptive me
what first Drew you all together you're
such an Eclectic bunch I think
disrupters recognize each other no no
yes you've used that word before to
disrupt us well what does that mean this
is Edward Norton playing miles Braun
holding courts obnoxiously with all his
friends at the sunny day by the pool
please decide this would be a great day
to give his theory of disruption and
he's telling Blanc who's doing his best
to look interested what disruption means
and the whole time we know that Andy is
standing off to the side staring at
daggers at him and she's about to bust
in and tell him some stuff
that's
the infraction point
that's the place where you have to look
within yourself
and ask am I the kind of person who will
keep going
wow
um
that was some real red pill stuff miles
the ndi build Alpha with
she believed it oh I believed it
and we know I feel like in every movie
there's like one sequence that
editing-wise is kind of
a big thing you keep coming back to and
the disruptors sequence from this day
because the other thing was because we
were shooting with three cameras because
we needed to to get all the coverage and
get everything in the day it also meant
we had a lot of footage and Bob I know
that this was something that you chewed
away on for a long time absolutely I
mean I think we
spent an enormous amount of time on this
the scene I mean first initially and
then and then as we continued to put the
movie together and a lot of that does
really come down to an embarrassment of
riches because there was so much great
stuff from from everyone and you just
have to kind of have the discipline to
you know make the choices and and and
make sure you're you're serving the
scene in the movie as a whole and the
scene is written is also a bit longer so
we we actually had to lose some things
that worked really well in the service
of the film you know you're playing Andy
you're obviously Helen playing Andy but
the audience doesn't know that yet and
you're slightly drunk but the audience
doesn't know that yet what was your way
into it would you remember this game
like what was your approach this was a
big one yeah I remember having a
Ali about this because this is the first
time that
from who they think is Andy but it's not
it's Helen right so there's a certain
part of me that has to
um make sure that Helen is creeping
through right because you just can't
overnight jump to to being a whole
different person it's just not
believable so there were some moments
where I was like even in my accent if
you listen I was thinking about you know
certain places to put Helen's mannerisms
or a little bit of the the southern
twang like slightly in in it and I just
remember thinking you know this is the
first time they're going to hear from
Andy and when they watch this back I
want them to like see those small little
hints of uh of Helen so they're like ah
Can you spot the other thing
the real thing this group hasn't come
hey come on
oh lion
everybody knows who Lionel works for
that's no secret
and we know who bankrolled Claire's
campaign
remember Helen knows that somebody in
this group killed her sister
you know she knows that so she has to
have a certain level of restraint
because
if you know that someone killed your
loved one there's even some some certain
emotion that obviously would come out
but she's like keep the eye on the prize
we're playing the long game like don't
give too much away but really really
push them this is the moment where
they're going to get pushed and she
wants block to be looking around at
everybody and watching body language and
and um and everything and she freaking
hates miles Bryan so
it was like that moment that you know
she she her talking to him in this way
it was like a long overdue moment that
required restraint
and that anger that you've got
underneath there it was I remember I was
talking about this that it works both
for playing it as Andy and it works also
for once the under layer of playing is
as Helen obviously and different what
about the drunk element of it because
there are some really nice little subtle
things that you do that lay in the fact
that Helen kind of has the gut you're
going to learn the second half Helen has
the guts to step up on the stage and do
this a little bit it's a bit of Irish
courage because she's been Downing these
kombuchas
yeah so I mean that is what kind of
gives her that liquid it's like liquid
confidence but she's not entirely like
so drunk that she's she she she forgets
what she's supposed to be but there
needs to be like that element of like oh
when you watch it again like oh my God
this could have gone all the way wrong
if you had just
like she could have that accent could
have come out Helen's you know Southern
drawl could have come out and everything
would have been like
who is this this is totally not
every single one of you is holding on
for dear life to Miles bronze golden
titties
and each of you
'll stab a friend in the back to hold on
if you somebody went in and cut the
movie actually linearly and watch this
scene or right after what actually
happens previous to this which is you
and Blanc in the bathroom and blocks
saying and you saying this isn't
happening fast enough we have to push
him we have to do something we have to
shake up we have to push them and then
because the first time you watch this
scene you think that it's Andy you going
around it feels like you're settling the
score with everyone once you have that
information you re-watch the scene you
see and you can see in your performance
you are needling every single one of
them you were going around to the
purpose of pushing everyone's buttons
trying to stir the pot and get a
reaction out of everybody and it's so
cool seeing the focus that you've got
that that reads so well as and in both
of those layers at once it's quite a hat
trick listen it was all on the paper so
it wasn't all the things
but I remember doing the scene a few
times you remember that where it was
like we played it up even more but then
it was the subtle it was the calmness
and I'm happy we went with that tape
of of her like having a undertone of oh
I see each and every last one of you I'm
gonna find out which one of you killed
my sister you know that that anger was
under me but there was a certain just
like calmness you know that she had like
she was in control and that was the one
we ultimately because you could play
this scene so many different ways so
yeah
um I'd forgotten that yeah that that
control and that Focus that you got into
being what felt right about it
foreign
ly great material and certainly one of
the most fun things about you know these
sequences and putting you know the movie
together is just finding the the sort of
just the the precise path to put the
audience in the right place like not too
suspicious but feeling that something is
wrong and it's it's really a testament
to your incredible performance and all
the great stuff that you gave us that
we're able to you know put together
something that works as well as it does
my name is Helen brand and I came all
the way here from Alabama
well
what do you do in Alabama
I teach third grade so a lot of zooming
we've just watched our whole time on the
island with who we thought was Andy and
this is the big Magilla this is the big
Center scene of the movie that kind of I
forgets the movie and it's this midpoint
of the movie we flash back to the
beginning and we reveal this is actually
Helen and Chanel there's a lot to talk
about with you in this scene I'll start
by saying it just just in terms of
styling and wardrobe I remember I don't
know if you remember when I walked into
your trailer Cassandra and saw you for
the first time in the Helen look and I
walked I I literally you're sitting off
to the side it's a tiny trailer and I
didn't I like walked right by you I was
still looking for Janelle I did like a
double take I'm like oh my god
um because we have been in the Andy
styling now at that point for months and
then to turn and see Helen there and to
have it be that photographers at the
same but if you can talk about about
like what you drew I know you talked
about kind of you know growing up in the
South and kind of the accent and what
what did you draw from for this this was
the first time
first time Helen so I so I say like I I
wasn't up all night thinking about it I
was like oh my God oh my God oh my God
it's the first time the audience is
gonna see her you're not gonna make sure
the accent is right but and I'm like who
are you when I tap into her spirit and I
got with Daniel who was just like the
best thing partner I was in kind of Andy
mode for weeks and
transitioning over into Helen
um yeah you know it it took some I I
wanted to have if I I knew that I had
the time and that helped me you said
okay we're gonna do this for three days
I was like okay I don't have to feel
rushed
um and I can I can you know catch my
footing on it I was gonna ask you like
that scene where Helen is looking at
Andy in the more on the table I mean I
remember Ryan you showed me like a small
clip of it before
um it was like fully finished but how
how did that like it looks so realistic
in terms of editing you know I mean I'm
sure it's probably a longer process but
whatever the short answer is how do you
how did you guys make that happen Steve
came up with the way to do that I don't
know if you remember but we actually
shot with the camera on the side and we
shot it I think we got for that shot
like a you know a large sensor camera
which we didn't use for most of the rest
of the shoot so we we shot it without
moving the camera and we shot it on its
side so you had a long vertical image
and you had Helen U.S Helen up top and
then uh room for you you know we kept it
locked off and we had to change you into
Andy and brought you back and had you be
Andy down on the table and then the
movement that then we then zoomed in on
it and the Tilt from you as Helen down
to Andy is a digital one it's that's not
the camera moving that's Steve just
animating a digital tilt down to you so
that was all Steve came up with how to
how yeah and it's a really fantastic gag
and and uh you know the we get the
pieces and we put it together and you go
oh my God look at this because it's
really I just think it's to me it's one
of the most putting myself in the
audience's position I think it's you
know something extremely dramatic
because this is not what you're
expecting and I and to me it's it's
because well it looks like the character
that we've been watching all this time
about the character that's currently in
front of us now that juxtaposition I
think is really powerful the other thing
about this scene it's not just
introducing her for the first time this
is just thinking in terms of of the
screenplay and in terms of the movie and
how the movie how the movie works the
entire thing of telling one's chunk of
story resetting and telling that same
chunk again from a different perspective
for me that's a terrifying thing because
the fear is that the audience's
shoulders will sag and they'll think oh
we have to watch all of this again and
it if to me my feeling was in the script
okay it's not going to be enough to just
have it be from a different perspective
or intellectually seeing it from a
different character's eyes or something
we need something that's going to propel
the audience during that second half and
to me whether I put my chips down on and
the screenplay is introducing a
character who you care about introducing
emotional involvement in the character
which we kind of don't have in the first
half besides entry had going through a
lot of information the most important
part of the scene is that people needed
to instantly like Helen and get on her
side or the whole second half of the
movie wouldn't work yeah you're right we
had to be emotionally invested in Helen
and um you know I just I think I've
watched this film I've watched this film
over 10 times
[Laughter]
I don't see you know oh she was proposed
and playing you know two characters I
really really see the essence of that
island and the spirit of this woman who
who is Andrew here to avenge her
sister's death will get answers and you
want her to win she's smart but she's
and she's also authentic to just who she
is the beautiful thing about this role
is
um I get to play a character with
secrets
and so it was such a great opportunity
to be able to like you know have that
secret with me and obviously it's not
revealed at the beginning of this of the
film but just knowing that it allowed me
to dig deeper into the depth of of this
character and and to pull so much and to
play with so much uh with just knowing
that there's some secrets that I'm
hiding Bob this was another one where
there was a lot of footage we shot for
three days it was a lot of back and
forth this was the other scene that I
think in the edit we just we kept
squeezing it we kept seeing where we
could lift out the scene is so critical
and and yet everything that you're
saying is completely true because you
know instinctively you think okay now
we've had this big reset but you know
we're we certainly hope the audience has
enjoyed being where they were um you
know on the island in Greece and
instinctively you think they're going to
want to get back there as quickly as
possible which I'm I'm sure is was
absolutely the case so there was
pressure on us for sure to
um have the same Pace in a way that it
didn't outstay it's welcome but on the
other hand there's so much going on in
the scene because it's not only that you
know we're introducing this brand new
character
um you know more than Midway through the
movie
um but at the same time uh you know
Blanc is this is the first extended
scene that we have with him where he's
being himself because he's been putting
on an act for the whole time we've been
watching with the exception of his
introduction scene and that's a pretty
short scene and we don't you know so we
fight we see okay here's here's block
how he actually is and there's there's
so many uh uh items that are important
in the scene introducing the new
character finding out the person that
we've been watching is not the person
that we've been watching we find out
that um um it's her twin sister
um we find we find out that Andy has
been dead for a while so this is we we
thought that we saw Andy maybe die when
she was shot
um uh you know earlier in the movie but
in fact we we see her in a morgue which
I every time uh I I watch the sequence
we were putting together I always
thought you know sort of mind blown for
the audience for the audience at that
moment great thank you guys so much for
this this is great I miss you guys